[Music]
as far as we know lieutenant colonel stu
sheller of the united states marine
corps was the only officer in the entire
american armed services who said in
public what so many were thinking what
the hell are we doing what did our
leaders just do in afghanistan how did
they screw it up so badly and why is no
one being held accountable that's what
he said and he said it on facebook
here's part of it
the reason
people are so upset on social media
right now is not because the marine on
the battlefield let someone down that
service member has always rose to the
occasion done extraordinary things
people are upset because their senior
leaders let them down and none of them
are raising their hands and accepting
accountability or saying we messed this
up
so instead of answering his questions
the pentagon did what the byte
administration so often does they
punished him they tried to crush him
they court-martialed him and sent him to
jail to solitary confinement in the end
stu scheller pleaded guilty to those
charges meaning he's going to lose his
retirement benefits just before the
sentencing phase began today sheller
appeared to be in good spirits watch
what do you expect to happen today
we made our case
you know we left it all on the table so
we'll see what they do uh
i feel good about everything that i said
and we'll see
the man served honorably for 17 years
exactly the kind of person you want
protecting your country now he's gone
shortly after that a judge rejected the
prosecutor's request for a stiff
sentence he instead issued a reprimand
and dock sheller one month of pay the
judge also called for an investigation
into possible government misconduct and
thank god that he did that misconduct is
not possible it's certain
stu seller senior and kathy sheller are
the parents of stu shelton we're happy
to have them both on the show tonight
kathy and sue thanks so much for coming
on how is your son doing
he's he's doing well tucker thank you so
much for giving us this platform to
to bring our plight to the american
people and thank you to the congress
people and most of all thank you to the
americans that showed up it was the
americans that showed up
that spoke their voice that that stood
up with our son and that's the reason
he's not in the brig today waiting for
months and months to for a court martial
to finally happen it was because of your
voice and we just can't thank you enough
and i want to tell you that
accountability showed up in that
courtroom today in a big way
i would like to thank judge heinz for
carefully examining all of the evidence
not taking it out of context
listening to our son's complete and
total statement checking out his
military record recognizing that there
was not a single blemish on it until the
fatal day
of the botched withdrawal from
afghanistan and the 13 service members
killed he recognized it for what it was
he gave the lenient sentence and we just
cannot thank you america enough you see
i have teeth i can smile well it's it
and we're grateful that he's out but
what a sad day for the country because
i think all americans look at your son
reasonable americans and say that's
exactly the guy i want as a marine
officer defending us i mean mr shelton
your son spent 17 years doing in this
job like is he it must be poignant for
him to have to leave
it it's not over yet we all think it's
over it is not over so here's what
you're not going to hear from the marine
corps
spokespeople
it's not over
the plea
deal that stewart agreed to while in
prison
was to plead guilty which by the way was
always his intent he accepts
accountability yes so he pleaded guilty
to the charges he pleaded guilty to the
charges and
in return
the marine corps and the secretary of
navy
agreed to accept his resignation the
only concern we have is that there is no
time limit on that that could be a week
it could be a month it could be months
they still have him on a gag order and
that's why we're out here talking
tonight
i tell you what the the final decision
maker is the secretary of navy carlos
del toro
and he is responsible for signing his
resignation and accepting his
resignation
you can google the secretary of nagel
navy and you can find his address you
can find his email address we would like
an honorable discharge
and uh we we would ask americans to
contact the secretary of navy and ask
him to expedite it please i don't think
there's any doubt that they will and we
can only hope that lloyd austin will
plead guilty and resign his job because
he deserves it much more than your son
we appreciate coming on tonight and i'm
sure we'll see you again mr micheller
thanks